hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our 1858
match between johanna koblenthal and
paul charles morphy and this is the last
game from the match we'll be showing
uh it's been it's been a lot of fun and
uh but you know
all good things must come to an end but
no worries there are plenty of other
matches against other uh very
very strong opponents uh so like i said
the last game will be showing and things
not
looking all that great for uh for our
good friend laurenthal
not only is he not close to winning the
match but uh well
he's just doing very poorly in the match
he did play that beautiful
uh sort of immortal game against morphy
but morphy had
an even separate bet uh with leontal
saying that he will not score even five
wins in the match
and so far uh low until not not very
close to this
uh but uh regardless of that it's a very
nice game let's check it out and then
we're talking uh gonna talk about
where we are heading with the morphe
saga who who is he playing next uh you
know what's happening with
with howard stanton and so on uh so
let's check it out uh laurenthal with
the white pieces opens with
e4 as he usually does we have e5 knight
to f3 and
knight to c6 and here we have bishop to
b5 and it's uh pretty pretty incredible
this game is uh
well theory wise as if it was played in
in 2020 as you'll see
so a6 morphe goes for morphe's defense
uh
imagine that we have bishop to a4 and
knight to f6 we have castles
uh and now b5 challenging the bishop
bishop to b3
and now bishop to c5 a capturing an e4
is something you just don't do because
well nowadays we know theory
but it seems in those in those days
morphe probably didn't know
theory about this but uh he knew that he
of course preferred development to
material but we will show it as it's
very interesting
uh for example if knight captures an e4
you can bust open the position with d4
the blacking is still in the center of
the board
and if captures for example rookie one
d5 it seems like black
defended everything perfectly there's
this very nasty knight to c3 idea
and black's position will be incredibly
difficult to play for example
you capture the knight the bishop
captures on d5 attacking this knight
attacking this knight
and well it is just a
terrible terrible position for black
white white will be able to win this
easily
so after this uh bishop to b3 morphy
just continues development with bishop
to c5 and now a c3 preparing to
strike in the center with the d4 with d6
morphe now adds another defender here
prepares to develop the light square
bishop
and d4 now we have e captures on d4c
captures and bishop to b6 we have bishop
to g5
uh this is the the main theory even even
today in 2020 maybe not in 2020 i think
the last time this was played it was in
2018
uh but still h6 is the main was the main
continuation here
however uh here in the position morphe
played bishop to b7 and
it is as of move 10 that this position
position has never
been reached again so let's see how
staunton deals with this he continues
developing
knight to c3 and now knight back to e7
morphe prepares to shift the knight uh
over to the king side and he wants to
start uh well
opening up the position here with c5
uh we have broke the e1 by low enthalpy
and now
h6 morphy says okay you decide what you
want to do with
with this bishop you can double my pawns
however that will give
me the open g file uh for my rook to
attack and with the bishop pair so
nicely slicing over the
uh the board it's not going to be very
pleasant so uh lentil goes back
bishop to h4 and morphy just continues
the attack g5
we have bishop to g3 and now instead of
castling morphy says i'm just going to
play king to f8 to get my king
a little bit to safety because i still
want to probably open up the the king
side and
use my rook uh for attacking purposes so
queen to d3
uh continuing development e5 was also
very interesting here but
uh these are very old games unless it's
super interesting we're not going to
dwell on it for too long
and morphe continues with c5 striking in
the center
and also there's this very interesting
idea of i'm not going to mention it
since i'm going to ask you to pause the
video later on
but here e5 now with one move delay and
d captures an e5 by morphe and here we
have bishop captures on e5 and the
position is incredibly interesting uh
morphy's knight is hanging he cannot
move the knight because the rook is
hanging
so what would you play here this is not
the real pause the moment
uh was the video moment uh in this video
there's going to be another one so this
is like uh
like uh secondary
uh not as important one because it's
mostly you have to figure out how to
defend properly
but still feel free to pause the video
and what do you play here for morphe
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
only move that works here for morphe
and that is c4 you don't care about this
because an attack on the queen
uh well uh requires white to act and you
cannot
just uh continue by grabbing pieces so
c4
attacking the queen queen to e2 uh
getting the queen out of the way and
only now knight to g6 you defend your
knight uh
white's bishop is still under attack you
have to go back knight goes back and
then knight to f4 ended the position
uh all of a sudden comes very much alive
and you know
who who can really tell what's happening
here uh white hat
black has beautiful knight here the
bishop pair is slicing all the way there
if you if you open up the g file then
you also allow morphe the g file to use
for attacking purposes
so it's uh it's a really crazy position
where morphe really should have played
c4 however morphe defended
uh his uh knight here with king to g7
but now
this simply doesn't work because knight
to e4
and now there's a problem your knight
here is attacked twice it's also pinned
you cannot move it so only move bishop
captures an e4 this is what morphe plays
we have queen captures on e4 and now
knight the g6
adding another defender here uh also
interesting
uh is rook to e8 just to show you uh how
how how easily white can win a position
like this
uh is just for example captures an f6
king captures and queen h7 and there's
just
nothing for black to do you can't go
back f7 is hanging and well
if you prevent the attack on f7 you can
go knight e5
again attack f7 and for example uh if
rook to f8 then knight to g4 is just
checkmate the the king has nowhere to go
all of these squares are taken
and that's just it a beautiful checkmate
with the king on f6
so this is uh only one of the
possibilities that uh
could happen here if morphe uh defends
with
anything less than than perfection so
here morphe goes knight
to g6 and now the queen is also
defending the f6 knight so you don't
have to worry about
any trickery uh however uh here
a lot of moves are possible we're just
gonna show one that's incredibly
interesting
uh but i was not playing in the game and
that is bishop captures an f7 and this
is just an
incredible move uh because after king
captures
you first capture here on f6 queen
capture so everything is forced and now
queen to d5
preparing to bring your rook into the
game looks uh
looks a bit weird because you it kind of
looks like you don't have ways of
bringing more attackers into the game
and you're down material
however after the king moves you're just
going to bring the rook into the game
and after queen to f7 preventing any
captures because the queen would hang
knights to e5 now attacking both the
queen and the knight and after captures
captures with
check king g8 now you're just gonna play
rook to e7
uh the queen has to be careful where the
queen goes otherwise you're getting
checkmated
and after let's say queen to g6 guarding
the g7 square now queen to d5
check and now it's game over because the
rook on a8 hangs and you're just gonna
be up material and easily winning for
example king of
rookie six first attack the queen now
the queen has to react and
the rook will fall with check
so only one of the interesting options
uh uh lentil has in this position bishop
captures on f7 really an
outstanding move however he goes for
queen to b7 instead puts pressure on f7
this way
and also puts a little bit of pressure
on the bishop here so the queen is for
the moment stuck guarding the bishop
however
morphy finds a move that brilliantly
defends against all of this
rook to a7 now the queen is has to go
back uh we have queen back to c6
and now uh while there are a lot of
moves you could play like c
captures on d4 morphy decides to go for
c4 he opens up the
dark square bishop a little bit but
maybe capturing on d4 was better as
it would do the the same thing you could
later push the pawn
and uh well you don't really gain all
that much by
shifting uh white's bishop to c2 the
white's bishop is actually much more
useful on c2 than it uh
was on on f7 after the white queen was
kicked away
but okay here morphe should continue
with knight captures on e5 remove a very
strong attacker
however morphy plays bishop to c7 he
decides to
get rid of the attacker this way but now
now it uh
just doesn't work he gives uh levanta an
incredibly important tempo he plays rook
a to d1
and now there are problems if you if you
exchange something like characters
captures then the knight is hanging the
queen is hanging there's also this you
have to be very careful
and there's simply not much uh for you
to do if you go knight to d7 e6 is
coming it's just the
entire position crumbles and it's going
to be terrible
if you capture then the knight becomes a
weak and everything everything just
falls apart the rook can come up to the
board
uh just terrible terrible position for
for morphy
so instead we have queen to e7 morphy
decides to
move the queen out of the way however
you are placing the queen right in front
of the rook
uh but okay uh here first we have bishop
captures in g6
and now while you could capture with the
f pawn then
d5 is incredibly strong and now you're
threatening d6
there's still so many things hanging
it's very hard to play for example
captures captures
and now you get this position where uh
the material is kind of equal
morphe is up a pawn but uh elemental has
a beautiful past
deep on he has uh well his rooks are
excellently placed the knight can easily
come into the game and it's
just a much uh much better position
so morphy doesn't like this instead he
plays king captures
uh but it's pretty much the same thing
d5 threatening
uh to play d6 here so bishop captures
with
knight captures on e5 now comes with
check as the king is on g6 king g7
and now uh as the queen is once again
aligned with the rook
uh he goes knight to g6 attacking the
queen attacking the queen this way with
the knight attacking the rook
and of course you have to react to this
you could try giving up the queen for
two pieces like
characters captures and captures however
after d6
white has a bit too much compensation to
go for all of this
so after this knight to g6 idea we have
queen to d8
uh and now uh uh alone tell just goes
after the rook we have knight captures
on h8 king captures
and now d6 continuing to push the pawn
king to g7 bringing the king back adding
one more defender to the knight
and then now a4 uh lointel goes uh
uh with the idea that he wants to bust
open this
uh pawn chain here he doesn't he doesn't
think it's uh it's very good to leave
like that
uh because it's also very easy for
morphe to create a passport just b
for c3 and already there's a pass pawn
so first
rook the d7 by morphe he he gives up one
of the pawns to take care of the the
uh d6 pawn so we have eight captures
captures and captures
and now rook captures and d6 but uh says
i'm up for the exchange i i really don't
care here
so here we have queen captures on c4 and
now comes
h5 morphe is now down the exchange and
also down a pawn
but he will still try he still has a
knight and you know as long as morphy
has
at least a night it's it's never over so
here you have
h3 making some breeding room for the
king and knight to d7 the knight is now
uh coming to e5 we have rook to e3
uh now uh with ideas of rook to d3 and
also
helping out with the defense of the
third rank we have knight to e5
attacking the queen and now only now
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the absolute simplest way to win
this position
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on playing really
any move because black
because white is winning here however if
you found the move
that love intel played which is the
absolute simplest way to win this game
then congratulations as you are a true
master of simplicity
uh and that is rook captures on e5 this
is absolute simplest as it trades that
down into a king and pawn end game
with white being up an extra pawn and
here uh elemental just shows that he
understands pawn end games and that
morphe can safely resign here
which he does as it was in this position
on 38
that paul charles morphy resigned the
game or rather maybe he didn't resign
maybe they
played it on because the official
notation has
three dots after queen to c3 so the game
might have continued
uh into an end game however i i i do not
know such things maybe it's possible
maybe maybe not but however the game is
completely winning and uh
we'll we'll just call it morphe resigns
here even though he could have played it
and lost that
doesn't really matter so it's uh
incredibly
easy to play this with white for example
captures captures me
you don't have to capture but at least
now the the the black king is closer to
the white pawn
uh but it's uh sorry about that it would
be too
easy for for white to uh play this for
example king e2 king d5 king d3 you gain
opposition you you protect your pawn
and now it doesn't matter whatever you
play after a few more moves uh
black will not have any moves to play
and then white just uh
trade trades everything there's not much
to be done here
uh captures captures you're going to
play captures captures and after another
king move let's say king e4 you're going
to eliminate
this spawn black has to tend to this
pawn and you're just going to move the
king and
queen the spawn so incredibly easy end
game and of course
morphe uh resigns it before any any any
of this happens
uh so after this uh queen to c3 move
morphe resigns
before like i said probably before even
going into into an end game
so a great victory for yohanyako blind
however he loses the match uh pretty bad
as out of the 14 games they played uh
lemental won
three uh two games were drawn and the
morphe won nine
games so this is uh not only winning the
match but also winning his personal bet
with love and thought that he will not
uh uh
win five games uh which is which is
pretty awesome however
something that i didn't think would
happen because uh of course solomontel
wanted revenge
for his loss to morphy uh in in 1815 now
eight years ago
uh after the match he he told morphy
that uh well
uh morphy only won games due to
lowenthal's uh
oversights and uh that he was it was a
much better player but that he was just
playing
uh well lesser moves now and morphe
thought this was very rude of him and uh
i mean it's not morphy's fault
uh if he doesn't play every move
brilliantly i mean it's uh
it's your game play any move you want uh
but yeah lointel was like this and i
guess he was still very
very much hurt about not not getting his
uh
revenge after waiting waiting for so
long
so this is uh uh how the match went i do
do hope you guys enjoyed it it was a
really enjoyable for me alone till got
his
uh immortal game against morphy so let's
not forget that
uh and now what happens next in the saga
will uh finally paul charles murphy face
his nemesis
uh the legend howard staunton uh or
will something uh else happen well uh
morphy uh
still trying to get a match with
staunton staunton said when morphy first
came to england that he will need at
least a month
to prepare to you know brush up on his
openings to
uh well to see probably how morphy plays
that's why morphy is playing against all
of stoneton's minions
but still the match is not happening and
now
uh uh staunton says that he will
maybe be able to play after the
birmingham meeting that
both him and morphe were planning on
playing and then
well things are still heating up i will
show two letters uh
uh between morphe and staunton but we're
gonna
save that for later because now a very
very strong player is returning to
england
one of england's finest and that's henry
bird and
morphy will play a 10 game match against
henry bird while waiting for a reply
from howard staunton
uh and uh not all games were saved i i
think only
four or five games uh four games are
available out of these 10 games so
we're gonna show all four of them as
it's incredibly interesting and we still
haven't uh well we haven't shown all
that many games by
henry bird uh on this channel and he's
uh he's a pretty famous guy so
uh that's where we're going next in the
morphe saga
uh that's uh the game i do hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
aldo fosco lawler music jack mahoney
william f field and robert
arathun for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching
and i will see you soon continuing the
morphe saga cheering up on your
wonderful suggestions and uh whatever
else happens
in the chess world uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day